ladies and gentlemen of course lot
number nine
fifteen million two hundred thousand and
selling
a trove of artwork amassed by real
estate tycoon harry macklow and his
ex-wife linda during their nearly six
decade-long marriage brought in a
combined
922.2 million dollars at sotheby's over
the last six months
this is a record for the most expensive
art collection to ever sell at auction
according to christie's auction house
on monday the second half of the maglow
collection brought in
246.1 million dollars over 45 million
more than expected
the first auction in november brought in
a record
676 million dollars for 35 pieces of art
marking the most valuable sotheby's
auction in its 277 year history
the maclos collected pieces by the
world's elite contemporary and modern
artists
sotheby's called their collection the
finest art collection to ever come to
auction
[Music]
the mac was divorced in 2016.
during divorce proceedings the former
couple's legal teams went back and forth
about the value of the art collection
in 2015 christie's valued the collection
at
937.5 million dollars in an insurance
estimation combined the two sales
surpassed the previous 832 million
dollar record set by the late banker
david rockefeller and his wife peggy in
2018 when their collection was auctioned
off to charity according to celebi's
the last 30 pieces of the maclos modern
and contemporary collection included
landmark pieces by mark rothko andy
warhol pablo picasso alberto giocometti
gerard richtner sigmar polk john d
buffet and william de kooning that the
couple collected over their almost
60-year marriage
rothko's untitled a painting from 1960
which had never before been displayed in
public before the sale fetched 48
million dollars and was the most
expensive piece of artwork auctioned in
the second event
another standout of the sale was one of
warhol's final works a self-portrait
that was completed just months before
the artist's death in 1987 that sold for
18.7 million dollars
harry macklow is often reported to be a
billionaire but in 2019 forbes estimated
that the couple had a net worth of
between 900 million and 1.1 billion
dollars before the divorce
a figure that included their massive art
collection
in 2018 a judge ordered that the couple
split their fortune in half
forbes estimates this left each of them
with between 450 and 550 million dollars
at the time
you